All right, everybody, so here is example number one looking at GPP USD on the six minute time frame
So the reason why I'm looking at the six minute time from is because if I go to the five minute time from
There are two for body gaps here one here and one here. So remember as I said before
the
Leg that takes out liquidity or does a break of structure must only have one for your value gap and over here
You can see we took out this high here and also these
this high over here
once again and
Let's see if we got something else if we took
And you can clearly see this old
liquidity was taken out so
Now once it was taken out
We had this fairly up we draw this along like that and remember we we're gonna trade during the kills on ours
so from 2 a.m.
Right till
11 30
Now what happens here after liquidity sweep and break of structure most of the people
would be going long of
this fairly gap because they would consider this as a break of structure
Right
But this is basically an SMC trap
Now what happens price closes below this level right here my entry would be on the retest
oops my bad
Right and first of all I will adjust my take profit level. So this is right here
Now it's giving me one to one to one point zero five
So I can just move it slightly up like that until it gives me one to one at least
Now this is where I would go break even and this is the closest
low
Okay
not this because
This low was created
After the inverse trivial gap was formed
Okay, so this is not going to be a take profit level because
This price section doesn't matter
For your draw on liquidity you have to look at the previous process which was this leg, right?
So we created inverse look to the left which is the closest low that is gonna be take profit level now over here
you
Could have taken full profits or could have gone break even and held the trade
until this level was taken out or even this level was taken out
Okay, so
You could have held this would have given you one to one point five or you can have gone for one to two
Very simple and very very powerful. Let's move on to the next example now